all right Cindy hello Cindy uh where are
you from where'd you grow up
um a little small Midwest area between
Springfield Illinois and St Louis
Missouri
um Livingston Mount Olive area 55 kind
of goes right between it one's on one
side one's on the other
tell me about your childhood
Ah that's interesting I call it the
sequence of Unfortunate Events lately
my mom and dad unfortunately
no not unfortunately fortunately because
I have no idea why they were even
together got divorced when I was five
um they hated each other
my mom
went off to find herself more or less
and my dad found this lady that had
three boys
my childhood was
a sequence of events that was
unfortunate for sure um
I was five when
my dad
met this lady
and she had three boys
and that's when I got
nobody heard me after that they were the
ones that were important
um
I bounced back and forth between my mom
and dad
I moved schools 17 times and never even
graduated
I'm still working on my GED
um at the age I was in fourth grade so
we figured it out I think it was like
10.
I was living with my aunt because my mom
had a boyfriend that was beating her up
and she was drinking and she didn't
think it was safe for me to be there so
I went and lived with my aunt
I love my aunt her my first sentence
when I was little was I want to go to
Aunt DD's house she's my
I want to be an aunt like her and I am
thank God
but I went and lived with her and my mom
kind of forgot me at that time
so my dad come back and went to court
and got me
when
I moved in with them
back in with them I was approximately 10
11 4th grade
and there was three boys in the house
and it was two years two older one
younger
and they
I don't want to say names but the the
middle boy was the favorite
my dad's favorite the sun he never had
my mom was busy with her life
I was just there
it's kind of like Cinderella actually
as I think about it now
cooking cleaning
I had to have like five loads of laundry
done
the house swept mopped
and then one day
did one
now step brother that's two years older
than me
the favorite one
came into the laundry room
when I was doing laundry
and that's when the abuse started the
sexual abuse
hi
I didn't realize that's what it was then
I wasn't getting
the love and the attention that I
deserved
from anybody but my grandma and my aunt
so when this person did this
they gave me the attention that I wanted
and even though I was saying no I mean I
was only nine ten years old
and I I see the freezer and everything
and at this time I mean I am telling
people that I don't want to be left
alone and I'm scared and everything you
know I tried everything never to be left
with him
But as time went on he was the one that
was always watching us if we were out in
the fields working in the fields
well Cindy go with him in his truck to
unload the hay
we need something from the grocery store
because we lived out in the country
Cindy
he's going to take you to the grocery
store
I hated it
because going to a grocery store he also
knew where every rock pile was going to
be
he told me nobody would believe me
and
he was right
I got my butt beat one time
because my stepmom found my little
brother's
teddy bear
in his closet
with my underwear stuffed in them
why they weren't bloody they weren't
nothing like that so why would I even be
hiding him like that in their room
but I got in trouble for it
I didn't say nothing
I wasn't saying what he was doing to me
I didn't know it was wrong
I it was a tension that I was I wasn't
getting it from anybody else especially
when I was that young
then
I've seen
weekly readers
another
unfortunate sequence you know everybody
gets the weekly readers in school for
kids and I'm sure most people I mean you
know how you go ask your mom for one
thing and Mom says no so you know you're
gonna go ask your dad if he's in another
room
I did that one time
wait about it was either Michael Jackson
book
or uh poster
and it came in and in our family
my dad was German
and
the women waited on the men
when we sat down at the table it would
be my dad
my stepmom
one of my brothers Step Brothers me and
the other two
my dad needed anything during supper my
stepmom got it
if the boys needed anything I had to get
up and get it
well the one that was abusing me he made
it almost in every night ritual that as
soon as I would put food in my mouth he
would take his cup and jiggle it
that's kind of a running joke now at the
family
even to this day
about how the boys would do that to me
my niece she flat out told him you're
lucky because I would have just dumped
it over your head thank God she had some
spunk and she doesn't let
she didn't let them do it
well one day we were the Weekly Reader
order come in
I was so happy but I knew
I mean I'd already been
whipped for taking something out of the
mailbox my dnf slips
and when I say whipped I don't mean
patted on the butt
sometimes it was on all fours with our
heads against the wall
and mine you my dad is your height
but a lot bigger his arms we used to
hang from his arms he's a farm boy hey
straw
my stepmom every time that we would get
in trouble she'd always make sure to
call get a hold of my dad or wait until
my dad got home my dad liked to drink
too so that was even more
well we were sitting
at the table and I brought it out
because the table was where
every night we had to be
no matter what the table that was my
dad's thing being German you eat
together that's where we talked about
what was going on
they would talk sex talk all the time
shoot the boy the one that sexually
molested me
he kept him and his friends kept a
running total of girls they slept with I
think he was up to 200
and it does not surprise me
um and our they just talked about
everything and I didn't even realize how
not
healthy that was at that time
well when I brought that out an argument
occurred
and in between
that I had already been
in Springfield Memorial Hospital for
suicide
because I was trying to escape what my
stepbrother was doing to me I tried many
times
go to the next door neighbors call my
mom run away
that really turn away I just walked down
the road in the country my mom would
come get me
um but then there was sometimes I was
running away from my mom too because she
had boyfriends that was abusing her
so that night
one thing led to another
um table got turned over dad started
yelling at her she started yelling at
dad
it was unfair that he did that for me
and I'm a brat and I'm a grateful and
all this stuff
and uh
next thing
I knew my stepmom was against the wall
against I'm sorry against the
refrigerator
my stepbrother they weren't they weren't
even stepped then they were just dating
um come with him towards a chair and my
dad grabbed it and took his foot and
went like that and kicked him back
and after that dad told me to go in my
bedroom
and
uh
pack
because I was going to be leaving that
night that he was going to take me to my
Godparent one of my godparents house I
said okay
so I went in there and I was keeping an
eye out an ear out because if anybody's
ever any through any trauma
now I understand that you're on high
alert all the time I mean the sound of a
door the sound you're second guessing
everything
that was my life shoot I'm so tight now
I'm having issues be I mean I'm tight
now because of then
next thing I know I see my stepmom and
my well
and my dad walk into the bedroom
while he was pushing her
he walked out and the next thing I hear
is a zip click click
well I just figured that was her
suitcase because you know if they were
fighting she was going to leave too
no she walked out with a big deer rifle
and my bedroom door was here and their
bedroom door was here
I was in fifth grade at the time
and I was walking behind her in the
hallway
and I couldn't say nothing
and we we would always get the deer
rifle out because we lived in the
country and if we weren't hunting
because we couldn't hunt we couldn't
kill anything on our property but we
would look because I had a great scope
and we would look for the deer
I knew I was 11 or 12. and my little kid
head
I thought oh wow Are there deers out
there we're going to look at
wasn't thinking about all the fighting
it was so natural the fighting was
always so I mean okay
Turn the page two seconds later
nope
uh my dad was standing
at the corner of the living room and he
was bent down
turned off the TV and turned around and
there was a recliner chair sitting over
here and she slipped that gun
on the edge of it on the back
and all four of his kids were behind her
yelling no
dad turned around and he's like what the
hell are you doing
and she pulled the trigger
she's shouting right here
dropped him and it come out here
he got up
he was hobbling out to the car and she
was hoping
I'm trying not to cuss but I'm going to
here the damn actually thought she
was going to drive me to the hospital
she was like I'll take in he looks at
her and goes you just shot me
huh
yeah
so I get in the car with Dad he drops me
off more or less at the neighbors
and I call the ambulance tell them which
way they're going because this is
country so it's smart for my dad to get
in the car because he could die and
bleed out
he got to Dairy Queen and thank God they
found him
four days later
I walk into Memorial hospital and he
she's standing right there next to him
and I get told I forgave her so you have
to
no counseling no nothing
just simple that no DCFS
no nothing they didn't even shut the
cell door when they took her in
my dad almost lost his life
they got married three or four months
later
they're still married
they've been together I was five years
old when they got together and I'm 48.
right then I gave up nobody was
listening to me
I just went in survival mode
I disassociated now I understand I
disassociated with everything I was
being raped I was
I was in foster care they abused me
enough and put me in foster care
and they wanted me to go spend the
weekends with my dad who abused me
but just four hours with my mom because
she had a boyfriend and a husband that
liked to hit on her but never hit on me
come find out my caseworker were friends
with my stepmom
I'm getting that report now
my stepmom had made me look like a liar
I see it now because she knew the truth
about her son
she hated me
now
I've had to
I mean I'm 48 it started 40 years ago
the abuse the not being heard
I had court
I have a court document I forgot what
those things are called like the court
reporters that they type out
I have a whole court case from my
parents that I am multiply sane multiple
times to this judge I'm scared
of my dad I'm scared of being there
at the time now reading it I realized
what my mom's lawyer was trying to get
me to do
was what I'm doing here
and explain what was going on and what
was going on wrong but I didn't know it
was wrong
I mean shoot the hummingbird paddle is
still hanging in my dad and my stepmom's
dining room that they used to whip us
with
it's a joke
of how I was treated
found out
that she likes to tell my niece who is
very important to me
that I put myself in foster care
because I took the dnf slip out of the
mailbox
so I deserve to be whipped with a
switch for a switch off of a tree and
had lines and marks from here to here
that it was my fault
that I had to okay guys not just
you know people say eat of our soap they
think just put it in their mouth
no they cut it up
and had me chew it up
and when I puked it up I had to pick out
the pieces
but I put myself in foster care
now you might wonder why you just asked
me about my childhood why I still stayed
in contact with my family
I didn't for a while
but then a little girl was born to my
stepbrother
and I knew I had to make sure she was
safe
so I stayed in contact
I mean I had a miscarriage by my
stepbrother nobody heard me I told the
one lie I told
this that's where he screwed up I went
to the judge one time and told them what
my stepbrother was doing to me
they took me out of the home and put me
in foster care
mind you I have and I'm not exaggerating
at least 15 aunts and uncles
my dad's one of 12 13. my mom's one of
ten
and I went in foster care
that was scary and I was only
nine
no it was that it was it had to be 11 or
12 I'm sorry it was 11 or 12 because it
started at 10.
8 10.
at this was the one lie that I told that
made me a liar for the rest of my life
well so far
that everybody in my family when they
took me out of the home after I said
that my stepbrother was molesting me
after two days I told him I lied
because they put me in this foster home
that was scary
it was two hours almost away
the foster parents told me that they
could only take me out at night time
because I was a foster kid
and I remember going up to the bathroom
and they were doing that
not Red Rum but where you look in the
mirror and you're supposed to say
something three times
and something's supposed to appear as
kids they do it
the next day I told I told my worker I
lied
I was scared I was young
that was my biggest mistake because
that's what turned me into a liar
at 17 I went back and forth I got at 17
I'd moved out I was living with my
mom because at 14 actually
my dad lost custody of me
week-long custody battle from eight
o'clock in the morning until 4 30 in the
afternoon in Madison County
and my dad lost custody
that was the day that my dad broke my
heart also
he was mad because I broke his heart and
I know that
but he didn't see what my stepmom was
doing
she had him she had so many people she's
the Miss Perfect in town she's the one
that makes all the pies and the cakes
and all that stuff when somebody dies
she's the one that when you know
somebody's in the hospital she goes to
or when a nephew's in prison she takes
care of his stuff for three years
that you know that Superhero syndrome I
call it
going him taking me to my to my mom's
house that night after he lost custody
of me we were driving down the road
and he looked at me and he said Cindy
you're so lucky Betty's with us
because I would hit the biggest tree I
could to take us both out
he was serious
I didn't see my dad for four years after
that
at 17
I was trying to protect my mom from her
then husband and he hit me
and I called cops
which the cops were there multiple times
not for me ever
and
I gave him a week to apologize after he
got out because I mean come on the cops
have arrested him and he got back to the
house before I even did
and he didn't apologize and I went in
and I told my mom she was laying on the
couch
I told my mom
you might put up with it but I'm not and
I moved out
I ended up back at my dad's
I was 17.
I was working
there was so much more going on I didn't
have anybody
and the rape started again
he had even had a girlfriend that was
living there
but I I had tried to tell multiple times
I told my mom my mom she totally
believed me and she tried to fight
but every time they would get me to try
to tell it when I was younger at court
and stuff I didn't understand
that it was wrong
I didn't understand like I said getting
my butt beat like I was getting whipped
like I was was wrong so I didn't know to
say it
so at 17 when I moved back in I got
pregnant and had a miscarriage and it
was from him
and I will never forget it because I was
laying on the couch because I was on bed
rest
and he walks in because she must have
called my dad when they were at work
he stood at the end of the couch and he
goes mom is Cindy pregnant he knew
it didn't stop even after the
miscarriage
now I under now I'm working through not
blaming myself
um I'm working through not blaming
myself for my whole childhood
because I feel that if I wasn't here
then the problems wouldn't have been
here
my one thing that made me
survive my adulthood so far
it's because that little girl my niece
nobody would listen to me
and I couldn't allow that to happen to
her
so instead of
when I got married and moved out and
stuff
instead of just
cutting them off and putting that up I
had to protect my niece
until recently
when my niece got pregnant and was
bringing a baby in to the house I mean
into the family because I had made sure
my niece she's 18 I made sure I I was
you know I I was there I was she moved
in with my parents she was taking care
of my parents and I'm going to say this
my dad my stepmom
sucks his parents totally sucks
but his grandparents
they did
they try to do a great job especially
with my niece they were there when they
when she needed them
but I had to make sure because my
stepbrother
lives in a field School camper
in the backyard
mind you I forgot to tell you this one
the other brother that's the oldest okay
I'm pretty 51.
he has a house a mile down the road now
but he lives with them
because well the last time my niece was
out there he was heil hitlering
and he was the time that I was out there
he was putting holy water on us
he has used enough drugs and mental that
he's not in his right mind
so my stepmom has all three of her boys
that are 46.
50 and 52 still at home
my dad's there now with dementia
but the one thing is is when my niece
got to the age and I knew she was
protected I mean I lived out in
Washington state for 10 years with my
first marriage and I called this girl
all the time I made sure I come home I
would always make sure I made sure you
know I wanted to be that Aunt and it was
also to protect her
because nobody listened to me
and I had to be the aunt to make sure if
he was doing it to her
she could come tell me
now
I got to make sure that my niece my
great-niece don't have that
doesn't get hurt
now I'm a foster parent
I've taken all what has happened to me
and I try to be fair and I wish this
world could just be fair
you know if you don't do it to people if
you're not gonna have it done
to yourself if it wouldn't feel good to
you
and now
the truth is coming out I've talked to
the cops which they've already failed me
once when I've told multiple times and I
will say this I talk to the cops again
and guess what I'm getting radio silence
but that's okay
because now I know my niece is safe
and I always wondered when I was a child
what you know you wonder what your
purpose is in life
and last night pulling out of my
driveway my purpose pulled out of the
driveway and that was my niece and my
great niece
not even blood
I have no siblings
but she was raised by the same people
has the same issues I have
and that's been my life to protect her
and I might not have no kids
but I want to protect her and any other
kids I can I'm a foster parent now
I'm a casa worker
I've been married twice
I'm now Danny dating a gentleman that's
20 years younger than me
I've had gastro bypass I used to weigh
309 pounds once I decided to change my
life
and get the surgery all my friends told
me because I had gastro bypass like I
said
um I was with the guy that was an
alcoholic I mean I married two
alcoholics I mean come on I had no
standards as my boyfriend tells me now
Cindy you had the lowest standards
possible
and he's like how could you not come on
your dad got shot by your stepmom and
they got married
you know your mom spends years with the
guy that beats the crap out of her
so now I'm 48 years old and trying to
figure out myself because of my
childhood
and
doing this I want to thank you because
not understanding what was happening to
me when I was younger
and realizing that was wrong
that needs for me that needs to be out
there more
you know the people that aren't her I
wasn't that's my whole thing I mean I
was going to court
saying okay I wasn't saying that he
sexually molested me but he did
but I was scared because you know what
you're getting ready for me to tell you
the truth on Stan but you're sending me
home with this man
so how am I supposed
to sit up here and tell you
that I'm being sexually molested because
I already told a judge once and they
took me out of the home
and the one lie that I told
is what turned me into a liar and that
was that he didn't do it
it's amazing how often this day is a
secret
yep I think it saves a secret more often
than it's exposed yeah well because too
I feel guilty
coming up here I realized that
I feel guilty because I let it go on
I said no plenty of times there was so
many times that like
it was almost caught like one time he
came into the house and he threw me down
on the floor and he was actually sitting
like at his knees on my shoulders
it was getting ready to unzip his pants
and my dad walked in and he told my dad
she wouldn't get me a glass of tea
so I was getting ready to punch her I
got whipped for that
because I wasn't going to get him a
glass of tea
what was I supposed to do tell the truth
because I would have got whipped for
that because to my dad that was a lie
believe your kids
look into it come on why would I hide my
own underwear
in my Step Brothers
teddy bear in their closet
why did I get whipped with that
sometimes the parents don't want to
accept that their kids are done and you
know and that's exactly what it is she
has not accepted that her three boys
it's it's quite entertaining in a ha ha
way
um
so there was three boys and one girl for
us
now with the grandkids it's three girls
and one boy
and it's amazing how all the females
are doing great
they have kids they have jobs they
actually most of them work for the
government the state of Illinois
in the Cannabis industry
so you know they're they're checked by
the state and everything
but then her three boys and her grandson
hmm
but I was the one that wasn't going to
do nothing with my
I fostered eight kids
in three years
I am now going through ketamine
treatments doctor
prescribed ketamine treatments for my
PTS cptsd
because they call it complex because
it's been for so long
and uh
thank God that kind of
social media for that because that's how
I found out about all that I've been on
medication since I was nine years old
for depression bipolar
to come find out it could all it I just
got put on ADHD medicine and guess what
I've actually sat here this long at what
age were you put on
two weeks ago
two weeks ago okay my mind used to just
like wander negative thoughts all the
time
playbacks PTSD and Minds a lot of the
feelings what's up
oh God yes between the ketamine
helping with the negative thoughts
and me not and I've just like seeing the
world differently like taking the
blindfold off the world
and then the ADHD medicine
slowing me down
wow I thought it was crazy
I I had all the buzzing in my body and
all that and I this all the time you
know can't sit still everybody would be
yelling at me shoot one time there was a
small earthquake like we heard felt the
rumble you know how in In Living
Litchfield
and I was at my cousin's staying the
night and this is how bad I was
we I didn't feel the earthquake her
roommate comes running in and is
embracing herself saying guys did you
feel this earthquake and Trista looks at
me and goes oh I thought you were moving
your foot
because at the I always
had to be just moving and now the ADHD
medicine helped
um
I kind of my boyfriend's 28 and actually
I kind of feel like
I'm learning myself all over again
I'm trying things that I've never done
doing this
you know
um but
I don't have like I said to you earlier
I don't have no luck but I have faith in
myself
that I can make it and I just want to
help other people live a happy life
and
go on adventures
but I really just want the truth out too
I was made to look like a villain
I was made to look like a liar
my mom was made to look nuts
the reason she was nuts is she knew that
her daughter was being sexually molested
she knew that her daughter got pregnant
by her stepbrother
nobody would listen to us
not the judges
not the cops they're still not
I have five unanswered emails
from the officer that's supposed to be
looking into this case
nothing
so I'm doing it
and I'm getting
the dot the paperwork
and everything
because I investigate I found out I can
get my DCFS record I can get
so nobody can tell me I'm lying if
somebody wants you know she's so many
years proved me a liar
not no more guys this is the truth
the person that you think is so good
she could be good to you
but nobody knows what happens behind
closed doors
and behind the bedroom closed doors it's
even more scarier sometimes
all right Cindy thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you for
allowing me to I hope this helps it
already has good
thank you